oh but we just finished our European
tour yeah yeah goddamn yesterday
yesterday literally yesterday so
literally the grind doesn't stop we
finished uh nine shows and then we're
like let's record a bunch of podcast
episodes because we have not had enough
of talking yeah yeah was it nine shows
or ten shows nine shows oh [__] yeah
nine shows we're done
um but like unlike the American tour it
was way would you say it was more
intense or less intense it was more and
less intense at the same time and
unfortunately we'd have a beer on us so
we can only like cheers with our drinks
but cheers cheers
cheers to another
um tour over guys yeah uh but yeah in
the America Tour we had I think 24 shows
in six weeks yes uh six or seven weeks
and uh in this tour we had nine shows in
about a week and a half yeah so
technically it was more intense but I
think just because it was like a way
shorter time it felt less intense
overall yeah I think because I like near
the second half of the tour we got a lot
of questions being like oh you know we
saw the schedule like you guys did like
six shows in a row in six days in five
different countries does that not just
like [__] you up and like but I don't
know because we did we did three shows
in a row for the American tour yeah like
right now and I felt dead yeah that that
[__] us up so yeah so I was dreading
the six days in a row and I was just
like oh God I'm gonna be dead by the end
of it but weirdly enough it wasn't that
bad no I I don't know why yeah and I
think the reason why is because America
all looks the same and yeah it was
[__] my head up when I would I would
travel 15 hours and it looked exactly it
looked exactly the same uh like a lot of
them like Middle America looks so
similar that is true so I think I think
just waking up in a new kind of setting
every time it's like wow cool yeah a lot
of the countries were all about first
time right so yeah it was a little bit
more exciting I feel yeah and like I
think like comparing to some of the
American cities that we went to we went
to some amazing American cities and then
we also went to [__] Ohio as well uh
and there is there's no hires on this
yeah there is there is a big difference
between waking up and being like Oh I'm
in Amsterdam today oh wait Copenhagen
Stockholm and then waking up and uh
seeing a cod zombie map and I'm like oh
we are performing here yeah okay I'm
celebrating my birthday here yeah yeah
so uh the vibe which is very different
just because every city every country
was just a different culture we tried
different foods every day
um so that's enough about being nice
we've got to tear list the countries now
the countries
all right so okay first what we found
out gladly let's just get this out oh uh
France is the Ohio of Europe that is
something that we have found out I'm so
glad because I thought it was going to
be the UK funnily enough not many
countries clowned in the UK yeah for
context in the show we we ask ask the
audience to name a country in Europe
they would not like to be isakai too
yeah yeah France was generally number
one yeah only a few exceptions like when
Sweden and Denmark wanted to beef it out
yeah but everyone pretty much said
France all the time which I was proud of
because like as someone who's not from
Europe I didn't know that as just a
thing yeah what would the Australians
like French people
um we're like do you have any opinions
on them yeah really not really because
it's this is so far away where it's like
I mean you're never gonna interact with
like French people from France in
Australia like maybe every now and then
so it's like I don't know we're too busy
beefing with New Zealand yeah I was
gonna ask if we do a show in Australia
do you guys think you'd put New Zealand
on 100 I would be I would be shocked if
New Zealand is not at least in the top
[__] Tasmania or something [__]
hey I don't know I've never been to
Tasmania might be nice who knows I'm not
gonna I'm not gonna jump to conclusions
there yeah all right tier list food
rating
all right [__] Denmark hot dogs
change my whole life
I went to like spent six weeks in
America and I think I had one hot dog
and I was satisfied I had two days in
Denmark I had four hot dogs and that was
not enough for me I had four hot dogs I
only had two wow wow I love sausages
yeah there was definitely a sleeper hit
I mean I I'd never heard of people
saying that hot dogs in Denmark are good
but then apparently all Danish people
were like yeah hot dogs are good yeah
but why aren't they like flaunting it
more well because I think it's it's
someone's saying it's owned by the
government or something like yes it's
government subsidized right or like or
like control like the quality is
controlled by the government or
something it's just so big brain because
the same in Sweden as well yeah so
because all the hot dogs are just great
yeah it's so [__] good and they had
like the like you had like different
toppings on it as well so you could
basically build your own hot dogs with
some of these stands and so many of
these stands so there wasn't really like
a hot dog kind of like brands that you
buy there most of them are like I think
it was a brand uh was it well there were
Brands but a lot of them there were just
a lot of independent Sellers as well and
like some of the hot dog stands had just
like homemade sources and all of them
were just Godlike dude I knew it was
going to be goedded because the first
hot dog we had was the Ho the the
airport hot dog yeah and like normally
airport food you're kind of just like uh
you know give or take but yeah we had it
was just like oh my God it was just a
big brand idea I've never seen an
airport do this in Denmark as you're
waiting for your bags there's just tons
of food and drink places yeah literally
like two like 10 meters why do not why
do airports not do that because they
want to make you feel like [__] yeah
clearly I don't know maybe there's some
some weird rules around selling it at
the baggage I don't [__] know what no
one does this no I've never seen it but
like it was because I wasn't gonna have
a hot dog because I wasn't even hungry
uh and then we were just waiting for
baggage and I think our bags were late
and then I think it was one of you two
that was was just like I'm gonna get a
hot dog and I'm like all right you know
you you know I've been to America I've
had hot dogs before I don't I don't want
a hot dog in Denmark ew and then I saw
the hot dog and it was the fattest
looking hot dog I've ever seen with all
these different kind of kinds of topics
conversations like two minutes gushing
over a hot dog yeah it is really good I
do recommend it I mean Copenhagen is
renowned for having some of the most
best food in the world but my God
they're glizzy's got to be up there yeah
do you know do you know what sold me do
you know what do you know do you know
the biggest thing that sold me the hot
dog was like twice the size of the bun
you know sometimes you have a hot dog
and it's just a [__] tiny ass hot dog
bun controversial opinion I kind of like
it when the hot dog fits the [__] off
why is that bad no like if I had to
choose I would definitely choose a
little more sausages yeah yeah you gotta
have a few bites with just the dog and
then the dog a little bit of like tip
[Music]
because I want to taste like a little
bit of like what the hot dog tastes by
itself you know I want to have the taste
of the meat and then you have like the
combination afterwards and then you end
up with a little bit of bread actually
well I've been on a [__] bread uh
Odyssey on this for your trip so in
every single show I got asked the
question so God has your opinion on
bread changed and uh I can confirm that
uh bread just taste different guys what
can I say Revelation what what bugged me
guys that you were coping and you were
like we shouldn't have good bread in the
UK I was like no no don't okay I I stick
by that we do I stick by that you just
never looked for it gone well
you go into [__] Europe and you trip
over like a bakery every time you go
into a restaurant and they give you like
a basket of bread every [__] time
would you get that in [__] spoons no
you don't did you get a girl that's the
point right it's just not as like easily
it's not as like common but we have it
it's it's there gone I'm sure we have it
but like that's like saying okay yeah I
want to find a good Italian restaurant
you have to search up Italian food you
know that's that doesn't mean it's like
sorry can you believe I have to look up
a restaurant no if you want like good
food that is not from like your Cuisine
then you have to like look up a
restaurant that not only does the
cuisine but does it well right in in the
UK it's just like it's just harder to
find access to good bread and the most
most mass-produced bread it's just the
same old [__]
okay okay okay
absolutely not absolutely not and we
actually have a tear list oh [__] that's
so handy oh wow we have them already
okay this is actually super healthy I
guess yeah so uh let's let's start from
the top actually so we the first stop
was Ireland
okay we have Island there yeah uh Island
was solid I think it's just like the
nicest thing I could say without talking
sure you know I I really really [__]
love Ireland uh I do think Dublin is the
I wouldn't even say like the worst place
just like the weakest place that Ireland
has because you go outside of Dublin and
everything's [__] beautiful and you
go to Dublin and it's just like oh
what's there to do that uh there's the
Guinness Factory and uh there's a
whiskey taster also uh I've never seen a
higher concentration of white Americans
than in Dublin I think I saw more
Americans in Dublin than I think
yeah I can't even imagine maybe like the
Daytona 500 is where you would see that
many other white people but it was
insane I it was the entire Guinness tour
was just Americans really yeah uh and
actually too Fair one thing that we
learned while we were in Dublin is that
apparently they're like they're obsessed
with Chinese food like Ireland has an
obsession with like their version of
Chinese food yeah uh because John took
us to some Chinese food and it was it
was good but I don't think it stood out
compared to the other countries you went
to the dog I ain't going all the way to
double any Chinese food that's not how
that works I think Ireland could go in
uh oh god oh your spice bag
yeah I didn't know that was a I don't
know if it's a Dublin special or Ireland
special if Ireland's food was like not
compared to the other countries that
we're talking with here it would be a
solid it would hire but I think because
we have these other countries we need to
thin out this tier list yeah I want to
say seat here seed here are we talking
about just the food or just the Just
Foods don't count why don't work out you
know because then that's the tealist in
countries and it feels that feels weird
I I think that we do the food and I
think Ireland is a solid sea I think our
people agree because again if unless
we're counting Guinness's food yeah no I
mean it's liquid
I mean I will say B just for the
Guinness alone I had too much [__]
Guinness I'm gonna rate the Guinness and
I'm gonna put it in a beer yeah
100 that's a meal okay